[Applause]
about 100,000 people lined the banks of
the River Thames in London to watch the
celebrations thousands packed the
Shawn's ELISA
in the French capital to watch the
firework display at the after Triomphe
there was heavy security deployment
after the recent yellow vest protests
bad weather didn't deter crowds from
gathering in the Greek capital Athens
for a dazzling display over the
Acropolis people partied into the new
year in the Indian capital New Delhi but
the celebration started thousands of
kilometers away in Auckland Harbour in
New Zealand thousands of people watched
brightly coloured fireworks shooting
into the night sky city authorities say
the show at the sky tower standing 328
meters tall is the highest fireworks
display in the southern hemisphere a
couple of hours later it was the turn of
Australia's largest city Sydney
despite thunderstorms on Monday more
than a million people were at the
waterfront watching eight and a half
tons of fireworks go off the biggest
display the city has ever seen this was
the scene in central Pyongyang the North
Korean capital where the crowds got not
just fireworks but a laser and dance
show
and Hong Kong mixed it up with local and
Western melodies accompanying the big
bangs the beaches in Rio de Janeiro were
packed as the sky lit up and not to be
outdone tobias fireworks exploded over
the world's tallest building the Burj
Khalifa Barbara and Gupta our sera